j'étais Picasso depuis le jour de ma
naissance mais pas depuis le jour de mon
héritage et en somme c'est ce qu'on m'a
demandé et voilà ça c'est autrefois
c'était les l'atelier de mon grand-père
aujourd'hui ce sont les les salons que
j'ai restauré où j'ai mis un petit peu
de ma vie et puis et puis de mon âme ça
c'est une poterie de mon grand-père don
j'ai hérité que j'aime beaucoup ça c'est
une photo qui retrace la vie de mon
grand-père à l'époque où il y vivait
quand il était là bon ben il est il
venait tardivement le matin parce qu'il
se levait très tard parce qu'il peignait
la nuit il se fait ses amis ses enfants
ses petits enfants tous les animaux
avaient le droit de rentrer les chèvres
les chiens c'est vrai que j'ai gardé un
petit peu cette habitude en ce qui
concerne les chiens mais que bon la
maison étant plus sophistiquée je l' je
n'ai pas de chèvre mais l'âme de mon
grand-père y est toujours d'ailleurs je
suis contente d'avoir mis quelques
tableau qu'il a fait notamment le
portrait de mon père lorsqu'il était
enfant et puis ici c'est une photo que
j'aime beaucoup c'est mon grand-père
avec mon père quand il venait le voir
dans cette maison quand il avait le
droit d'être reçu donc c'est un moment
précieux parce que c'était des rares
moments c'était le point un petit peu
difficile d'être reçu d'ailleurs cette
table est un endroit un petit peu
symbolique c'était pas cette table là
c'était une vieille table de bois et
c'est là qui était reçu tous ces enfants
mon mon frère paabito moi-même Claude
Paloma et Maya et on se retrouvait là
quand mon grand-père se se levait très
tardivement on était un petit peu décalé
dans le temps parce que nous on
attendait depuis plusieurs heures et
quand il avait décidé de se lever nous
recevoir B on partageit quelques fruits
secs du thé avec lui et puis c'était
quand même un moment privilégié alors on
essayait de le vivre comme on pouvait
mais on se demandait souvent et c'est ce
qui m'a beaucoup marqué dans mon enfance
si on était reçu par notre grand-père ou
si mon grand-père était un roi un Roi
Soleil ou pourquoi fallait-il autant de
d'attente et de difficultés pour être
introduit auprès de
lui puis j'ai choisi ces poterie ces
assiettes ce sont des des petites choses
que j'aime bien c'est vrai qu'autrefois
bon quand je je suis devenue héritière
je je tournais les tableaux je tournais
les potrits pour pas les voir parce
qu'elle représentait toute l'intensité
toute la force que mon grand-père
possédait et j'avais le sentiment d'être
totalement écrasé donc j'avais pas la
force d'y faire face donc en les mettant
le dos au mur ben j'avais l'impression
que mon héritage était plus léger Marina
Picasso il semble que ça été difficile
d'accepter cet héritage écoute de
manière générale je crois que c'est pas
facile d'hériter matériellement on peut
penser que c'est très facile mais je
crois que psychologique c'est difficile
parce que derrière un héritage il y a
toujours une histoire et je crois que
dans la vie de Picasso l'histoire a été
très lourde il faudrait peut-être
rappeler qui vous êtes justement dans la
famille Picasso parce qu'on a tendance
un peu à à mélanger un petit peu un peu
oui oui je crois que la la la vie de mon
grand-père est un petit peu compliqué
bien moi c'est très simple je suis donc
la petite fille de Pablo Picasso je suis
la fille du fils légitime de Pablo
Picasso Paul Picasso qui est le qui est
le fils aîné de tous les enfants de
Picasso donc vous vous êtes
C héritiers nous sommes cinq
coohéritiers vous attendiez à cet
héritage à 22
ans non non sincèrement non déjà je n'y
avais pas pensé puis j'avais quand même
un père et je pensais pas que mon père
mourrait consécutivement après mon
grand-père donc oui effectivement
j'étéis surprise il faut bien rappeler
qui que tout le monde est est mort alors
vous avez eu trois morts successiv
quandme oui c'est très rapproché oui ce
sont des des des moments difficiles oui
perdre son grand-père son père et son
frère en 2 ans et demi oui je pense que
pour une jeune femme ou une jeune fille
c'est un bouleversement c'était votre
votre père qui était donc le fils de le
fils légitime de de Picasso il n'avait
pas hérité lui il n'avait pas mon père
n'avait pas hérité je crois que c'était
un côté assez joli de sa personnalité
mon père aurait pu à ce moment-là euh
avoir une certaine indépendance et il a
refusé de toucher à l'héritage de son
père il a voulu laisser le l'œuvre de
son père intacte je pense qu'il l'a fait
par par affection et aussi par
admiration il pensait surtout que cet
héritage lui appartenait pas que c'était
à son père c'était son œuvre et qu'il
fallait ben qu'il fallait le laisser
comme il était et ça l'a quand même
rendu très dépendant matériellement et
psychologiquement vous pourriez me dire
il aurait pu faire autre chose mais
malheureusement je pense que quand on
est le et je le dis aujourd'hui avec un
certain recul quand on est le fils de
Picasso on ne peut pas vivre comme les
autres c'est pas possible pourquoi bien
parce que quand on a un aussi puissant
on a l'impression je vais vous dire une
chose qui peut vous paraître négative
mais négative mais on a l'impression
qu'on est rien parce que c'est trop et
j'ai mis beaucoup d'années à le
comprendre et j'étais un petit peu en
colère après mon père lorsque j'étais
jeune en me disant comment il n'a pas
fait le nécessaire pour ses enfants et
au fond je me suis rendu compte avec le
temps surtout quand je suis devenue
héritière que c'était extrêmement
difficile de d'assumer tout ça et on n
plus de personnalité on dépend on dépend
de l'autre et moi même en étant petite
fille donc je suis suis pas concerné
directement j'ai des souvenirs quand
j'étais très jeune je disais jamais je
suis la fille de Paul pigasso je disais
je suis la petite fille de Picasso parce
que je pensais que je n'avais le droit
de parler que de cette façon et
aujourd'hui j'aurais beaucoup plus
d'affection et de fierté en vous disant
que que je suis heureuse d'être la fille
du fils de Picasso et non celle de du
Petitfils de Picasso mais ça veut dire
que tout ce trajet vous l'avez fait ces
dernières années oui oui je crois que
cette dernière décennie j'ai j'ai
vraiment fait le point j'ai construit ma
vie j'ai mis par de moi-même dans le
tiers monde dans mon humanitaire et bon
je me suis construit une vie et ça m'a
permis de de remettre mon grand-père à
sa place tout en restant très admirative
de tout ce qu'il a fait et si
aujourd'hui je fais tout ce que je fais
c'est grâce à ça aussi donc je dis avec
beaucoup d'humilité vous compreniez
qu'il était un artiste connu euh clè je
le comprenais en partie comme tous les
enfants petits mais j'avais surtout pas
envie de le comprendre j'avais envie
qu'il soit qu'il soit à moi et qu'il
soit un vrai grand-père donc franchement
ça me dérangeait il fallait qu'on soit
très disponible pour lui et ça je le dis
aujourd'hui en tant qu'adulte c'est
amusant parce que lui nous faait
attendre 2 heures même quand on avait 4
5 ans mais par contre quand on était là
même quand on était plus grand je me
souviens un jour de l'avoir énormément
blessé parce que j'étais avec mon père
et mon frère pu ça devait pas trop bien
se passer et j'ai fait le geste de
regarder ma montre et je l'ai vu
vraiment devenir livide il a eu le
sentiment que je m'ennuyais avec lui
alors que c'était pas ça j'avais trop
attendu j'en avais assez et au moment où
on me donnait mon grand-père ben j'en
voulais plus qu'est-ce qu'on vous disait
à l'école au lycée en grandissant avec
mon frère on avait développé avec
beaucoup de talent mais l'art de faire
croire qu'on était heureux alors qu'on
ne l'était pas et on avait une vie
contrastée puisqu'on était dans un
collège d'enfants fortunés et on avait
une vie très très difficile
matériellement chez nous donc c'était
très difficile de vivre une vie
contrastée et c'est pour ça que j'ai
toujours rêvé d'aller au lycée quand
j'étais enfant et pas dans des écoles
particulières qui était payé par votre
grandère je crois ce qui était pas très
intelligent parce parce que ça nous
donnait une vie encore plus difficile
c'est-à-dire lorsque vous rentriez à la
maison c'était retrouver notre quotidien
et un quotidien sans argentile voilà
mais c'est le fait nous d'arriver à
l'époque et notre petite mobylette et
puis avoir des enfants qui arrivent avec
leur rolles et leur chauffeurs bon on
est de suite différent et nous on
voulait pas de tout ça on voulait
surtout pas de ce qui représentait trop
donc on aimait mieux notre mère démuni
sur bien des plans que notre école de
riche je crois que c'est c'est c'est on
peut le comprendre les enfants ne
veulent rien d'autre que que ce qui est
vrai comment vous expliquezv que votre
grand-père ne n'est pas donné d'argent à
votre mère pour vous élever qu'il a payé
des études rendu compte j'ai essayé de
me l'expliquer longtemps mais c'est très
simple je pense qu'il faut pas en faire
quelque chose de de de compliqué mes
parents s'entendant mal leur relation
étit tout le temps conflictuelle mon
père recevait de l'argent et après il le
redistribuait comme il le voulait ou
comme il le pouvait mais au bout du
compte vous lorsque vous étiez on va
dire adolescent et jeunes filles vous
pensiez que vous étiez pauvre ou riche
pauvre comme votre mère ou riche
non je crois que la réalité je suis pas
d'humour mais je dis avec le sourire je
pense que j'avais tout à fait conscience
qu'on était démunis mais que çaavait pas
tellement d'importance il fallait faire
avec qu'un jour ce serait peut-être
différent parce que je grandiraai je
deviendrai adulte et je ferai quelque
chose par moi-même c'est ce que je
souhaitait le plus profondément donc non
ça me posait pas trop de problème ça en
a posé davantage à mon à mon frère parce
que lui était certainement beaucoup plus
marqué par l'image de mon grand-père il
s'identifiait certainement à cet homme
enfin il essayait de s'identifier à cet
homme puissant et c'est là je pense où
il a où il a lâché et je pense que c'est
une des raisons profondes de son suicide
il a compris qu'il n'arriverait qui
n'arriverait jamais à surmonter il a
désespéré avant avant l'heure et c'est
assez dur pour moi d'en parler mais je
crois que si on lui avait donné un peu
de temps supplémentaire bah il serait en
vie puis il aurait fait comme moi il
l'aurait assumé mais là il était un âge
fragile où les garçons ont besoin d'être
ben d'être reconnu soutenu par leur père
et même par leur grand même leur
grand-père aussi puissant soit-il il av
quel âge quand il est décédé quand il
s'est suicidé il avait 22 ans mais ça
aurait pu être évité et ça pour moi
c'est un profond regret parce que je
crois que dans des dans des famille
beaucoup plus simples les mots existent
mais quand ce sont des familles
puissantes comme ça le tout ce qui est
humain passe au second plan ce nom il
est attaché à votre grand-père est-ce
que justement avec tous ces drames qui
sont passés dans la famille à un moment
donné vous en avez voulu à ce grand-père
oui j'en ai voulu j'en ai voulu pendant
longtemps parce que j'ai eu l'impression
que mon grand-père était un monstre qu'
avait déclenché tout ça puis ensuite
quand même j'ai remis leurs choses à
leur place et j'ai reconnu que le génie
c'était une chose hors norme et queun
génie ne peut que finalement faire des
débordements et c'est ce qui est arrivé
dans ma famille comment vous viviez vous
à 22 ans lorsque vous avez été à la tête
de cette fortune vous é ça m'aff un
petit peu d'en parler toujours mais bon
ben j'aiété étudiante j'ai passé mon mon
bac philo et puis ensuite bon j'ai du
des difficultés matérielles et je
voulais rien demander à mon grand
grand-père donc j'ai travaillé je
m'intéressé beaucoup à la psychologie
donc j'ai fait des stages dans dans des
maisons d'enfants handicapés d'arrière
et profond et c'était pas facile de
porter ce nom de chercher des petits
boulots et bon j'ai paré au plus pressé
je su dire ce nom vous le portiez comme
une difficulté ou au contraire tout à
fait vous savez je me suis trouvé dans
des situations où quand je demandais un
travail bien sûr on vous demande votre
carte d'identité votre état civil et
surtout dans une région comme la Côte
d'Azur et surtout dans une comme valoris
où mon grand-père était très connu avec
mon frère on a souvent essui des
affronts parce qu'on souriait quand on
demandait un travail on nous dit enfin
je comprends pas vous n'en avez pas
besoin donc c'est très très difficile
quand on est 18 19 ans de il faut
rentrer la tête dans les épaulle puis
rien dire c'est on a vécu beaucoup
d'humiliation ce qui fait lorsque vous
avez hérité vous avez j'imagine arrêté
immédiatement de de travailler oui
qu'est-ce que vous avez fait vous avez
géré la la fortune non ser préten de
dire ça non j'ai été convoqué qui une
table d'héritier avec un commissaire
priseur un un administrateur on m'a
informé un petit peu de de l'avenir que
j'allais avoir sur le plan de l'héritage
mais j'étais vraiment pas concerné donc
c'était très très lourd je veux dire on
ne peut pas rentrer comme ça être
convoqué peut-être une semaine après le
décès de son père une table d'héritier
et vous dire ben voilà c'était des
sous-entendus vous êtes content voilà
vous êtes héritière votre grand-père est
mort votre père est mort votre frère
n'est plus là vous avez partagé toute
votre vie parce que j'avais 18 mois
d'écart avec mon frère vous avez partagé
tous les mêmes moments les mêmes
souffrances les les mêmes idées les et
aujourd'hui vous êtes toute seulle vous
êtes encore plus riche que s'il était là
parce que vous allez malgré vous m
mériter de sa part puis prenez ça et
ayez le sourire soyez contente non
c'était pas possible et en plus c'était
pas dans ma nature parce que j'avais pas
une nature matérialiste même au jour
d'aujourd'hui je suis quand même une une
idéaliste et c'est vrai que
c'était c'était vraiment cruel mais
c'était ainsi il fallait B il fallait
l'assumer alors comment vous avez fait
sur les années pour peu à peu accepter
et faire en sorte que cet héritage
devienne justement le vôtre j'ai entre
tempemps essayer de construire un petit
peu ma vie de femme puisque j'ai eu deux
enfants et puis consécutivement à tout
ça bon malheureusement la vie a fait que
je me suis séparé du perdre mes enfants
biologiques et je je suis tombée malade
après parce que c'était trop une
séparation de petits bébés tout ce que
j'aurais pas souhaité parce que je
voulais vraiment avoir une vie ça peut
paraître un peu puérile mais je
souhaitais avoir une vie modèle être
marié avoir des enfants pas pas de pas
de souci et puis ne pas vivre en tant
qu'adulte ce que j'avais vécu enfant et
malheureusement la vie a fait que j'ai
revécu pendant un certain temps
exactement la même chose donc j'étais
très j'étais très révoltée de cette
situation et j'en suis tombé malade je
pense que c'était le seul échappatoire
pour me retrouver moi-même et puis j'ai
pu réapprivoiser mon héritage me
m'occuper de ma collection en me faisant
aider par des gens hyper compétents
participer à des expositions et puis s
en prétention on a fait les plus belles
expositions dans le monde dans tous les
musées du monde j'ai j'ai redonné j'ai
redonné de la vie à cette collection qui
pour moi était morte rapprivoiser c'est
un mot fort oui oui j'étais Picasso
depuis le jour de ma naissance mais pas
depuis le jour de mon héritage et en
somme c'est ce qu'on m'a demandé et à ce
moment-là vous vous dites bon maintenant
ça suffit j'ai souffert je suis
peut-être devenue héritière mais
maintenant je vais m'occuper de moi-même
je vais être moi-même je vais plus être
la petite fille de Picasso mais Marina
tout court parce que je disais toujours
je détestais la peinture alors que
c'était faux aujourd'hui je l'adore j'ai
racheté des choses de mon grand-père
j'achète des des œuvres de tiers donc je
suis pas ind différente à tout ça la la
collection c'est combien de combien de
pièces ça j'aime pas trop ces questions
matérielles mais c'est vrai qu'il y a eu
énormément de tableaux énormément de de
dessins je je me souviens pas trop mais
je pense avoir hérité environ de 7000
dessins de de beaucoup de tableaux et
énormément de gravur c'est c'est très
important oui puis je suis une héritière
principale donc c'est vrai que j'ai
hérité de beaucoup de choses j'ai jamais
pensé comme ça mais oui mais parler
d'argent vous ça vous ça vous dérange
vous n'aimez pas ben moi j'aime bien
répondre aux questions qu'on me pose
mais c'est vrai que je ne veux pas
chiffrer en disant je représente tant je
trouve ça vraiment un moral et puis in
esthétique mais mais voilà lorsque vous
avez hérité enfin en tout cas des des
années après il éta évident pour vous
qu'il fallait que cet héritage serve
dans l'humanitaire serve pour pour
élever des enfants pour en adop
pour la Fondation c'est quand même c'est
une lueur d'espoir et je pense qu'il
faut donner l'espoir à tout le monde
finalement ce nom après qu'il a été
difficile à porter pour vous lour lourd
àortter aujourd'hui vous le vous avez
envie de le protéger j'y suis attachée
et j'ai envie de le protéger oui et puis
vous savez quand au jour d'aujourd'hui
on peut penser qu'on vend même ce nom
pour une
automobile c'est ce nom va rapporter de
l'argent bon moi c'est une chose à
laquelle je me suis opposée dont je
souffre beaucoup vous vous pouvez
imaginer le regard d'autrui tout ce que
les gens peuvent fantasmer à travers ce
nom vous vendez votre nom et vous avez
des milliards c'est c'est insupportable
entre vous donc les cinq héritiers vous
réunissez justement pour
savoir pour tous ces problèmes pour non
je vais vous répondre très franchement
il y a une une société qui a été créée
qui s'appelle la Picasso administration
et sans méchanceté je trouve déjà que
c'est un nom qui est affreux par rapport
à ce que représente mon grand-père parce
que le mot administration à côté d'un
nom d'artiste je trouve que c'est
vraiment mal choisi mais je ne fais pas
partie de cette société donc chaque fois
qu'une décision est prise elle est prise
à la majorité ils sont quatre je suis
seule donc là en ce qui concerne
l'histoire de la voiture Citroën je n'ai
pas été consulté je l'ai appris comme
tout le monde dans la presse ce qui veut
dire que vous n'avez pas beaucoup de
lien donc avec les les autres héritiers
avec non c'est ass triste je reconnais
qu'on a eu une vie on a été tous séparés
on a tous eu notre chemin qui était
assez galère et pas facile bien que dans
la hiérarchie de la souffrance je
voudrais pas être négative mais je pense
que que ceux qui ont le plus souffert
c'est mon frère pabito et moi-même mais
les autres ont certainement souffert à
différents endroits quand on a un enfant
adultérrain se battent pour un non c'est
pas facile ça peut expliquer aujourd'hui
d'ailleurs qu'il veuillent prendre une
revanche que je comprends mais il faut
quand même pas exagérer et si
aujourd'hui on voudrait protéger mon
grand-père il faudrait commencer à ne
pas vendre son nom à n'importe qui ou à
n'importe quoi aujourd'hui comment les
gens vous vous
regardent quel comportement ont-ils
j'essaie de pas trop y penser parce que
ça ser vraiment trop gênant et nibant
mais je vais vous dire quelque chose de
de de d'assez triste je crois quand on a
un nom une fortune on souffre beaucoup
de solitude parce que parce que c'est le
prix à payer c'est ce qui se passe un
petit peu dans ma vie bien que je sois
très occupé je ne m'ennuie jamais mais
bon des fois on aimerait avoir des des
contacts plus profonds plus et je vais
dire quelque chose de très dur mais
c'est vrai dans toutes les relations que
j'ai j'en ai
beaucoup malheureusement en grande
partie on m'utilise beaucoup et il y a
quelques années je le vivais bien parce
qu'au fond j'ai m donné et puis
j'attendais rien en retour et
aujourd'hui ça doit être l'âge on est
plus fragile et on on attend quand même
un petit peu en retour et je reçois
rarement je reçois rarement et là il y a
un déséquilibre là actuellement c'est
ainsi que je vis très mal parce que dès
que quelque chose est terminé bon ben je
je me je me retrouve assez seu et c'est
très dur est-ce que vous pouvez faire
peur aussi parce que on imagine des tas
de choses à travers ce M ce qui n'est
pas facile à faire je sais que dans ma
vie de femme j'ai pu faire peur à
certains hommes parce que je
représentais alors que le plus profond
de mes désirs était d'être la femme la
plus simple et d'être aimée pour
moi-même et je dois dire que c'est un
échec je n'ai pas réussi mais j'imagine
justement aussi par rapport au aux
hommes qui vous devez aussi vous vous
protéger non on doit bon nessaie de pas
trop y penser mais c'est vrai que
souvent vous avez des histoires d'amour
comme on en a toutes qui commence très
bien parce que justement vous avez cette
position mais qui se termine très mal et
c'est vrai que ça ça a détruit l'image
de l'homme pour moi et ça m'a posé
beaucoup de problèmes j'avais déjà perdu
mon grand-père mon père et mon frère
ensuite avoir des échecs de femmes dans
ma relation avec les hommes c'est vrai
qu'il y a eu un moment de ma vie où je
me demandais c'est vraiment c'est
vraiment cher à payer est-ce que vous
pensez que c'est le prix à payer
systématiquement lorsque l'on est
héritier d'un nom et d'une fortune ben
j'aimerais vous dire non mais
malheureusement aujourd'hui j'ai 48 ans
et le constat est que c'est le prix à
payer mais il faut pas je crois je pense
pas il faut pas s'en détruire il faut se
dire c'est comme ça non mais on a le
sentiment en même temps que vous êtes
comme vous avez fait la paix vous avez
compris beaucoup de choses finalement il
y a une grande sérénité qui est oui oui
c'est l'expérience c'est l'expérience
oui je suis sereine je le dis d'ailleurs
si je peux le dire c'est pas facile de
le dire devant des caméras c'est
justement parce que je suis sereine je
sais ce que je peux vivre et ne pas
vivre je sais ce que je n'ai pas vécu ça
je le garde pour moi et j'ai un profond
regret un profond regret mais c'est
comme
ça pour ne rien manquer sur ma chaîne
Inna Mireille Duma abonnez-vous et
activez la
[Musique]
cloche